nous avons ici une lettre
d'affranchissement qui constitue un acte
d'affranchissement de la nommée Niama
esclave du sieeur Jean-Baptiste
choffroid demeurant à
Saint-Pierre c'est un acte qui date du
23 août
1755 c'est un parchemin avec à sa gauche
un saut de cire rouge cette lettre
d'affranchissement dit ceci
louis par la grâce de Dieu roi de France
et de Navar à tous présent salut savoir
faisons que vu par notre conseil
supérieur de l'île Bourbon la requête
présentée par le sieur joffroid tendante
à ce qu'il pl au conseil de l'autoriser
à affranchir la nommée Niama native 2
agé 2 qu'il a acheté à la compagnie et
ce en considération de la bonne habitié
qu'il porte à la dite négresse oui sur
ce le procureur général du Roi le
Conseil a homologué et homologue la dite
requête et en conséquence a permis
auudur joffroid d'affranchir la nommée
Niama pour jouir des privilèges dont
jouissent les personnes nées libres et
ce au terme des lettres patentes Niama
rejoint donc en
1753 le groupe des libres
elle jouit désormais des droits
privilèges et immunité comme tous les
libres l'affranchissement est une
procédure juridique d'acquisition de la
liberté l'esclave ne peut être affranchi
que sur la permission du gouverneur de
l'intendant puis du Conseil supérieur il
est donc accordé avec
parsimonie le plus souvent par la
volonté du maître en considération des
bons servicees rendus et des preuves de
fidélité ou de loyauté alors
l'affranchissement est
limité on en compte avant 1848 que 10 %
de la population esclave moins d'un mois
après laffranchissement Niama donne
naissance à un garçon dont le père est
vraisemblablement son ancien maître cet
enfant sera reconnu puisqu'il portera le
nom de Jean-Baptiste lilé jaoffroid et
deviendra un des plus grands savant de
son
époque